so the average woman brings
communication no not the average woman
okay the slightly above everything okay
the slightly above average woman brings
communication feminism it should they
should and looks they should I like how
you're not answering the question I
asked it's like women when we you don't
like the answer that that we would have
to give it's like let me answer how I
want to answer okay so ask a question
one more time what does the average
woman bring to the table in 2023 so the
average woman it depends usually I guess
I'll remember that's a band work yes
it's banned okay so the average woman I
guess is everyone that is on social
media so they bring looks